the big SiC is directed by Michael
Showalter and stars Kumail Nanjiani as
himself in a story about how he met
someone who was very special to him and
the rocky relationship they had together
and how they came to appreciate each
other and how they traverse the
difficulties of being from different
cultures kamal is from Pakistan and Zoe
Kazan plays Emily the girl he's dating
and she's white and obviously from
America Kamal's background is very much
so that you adhere to your family's
wishes you pray often and you also
follow arranged marriage there's a great
line in the movie where he says in my
country arranged marriage is just called
marriage and that's what we're dealing
with here so it's about the complexities
of clashing cultures but that's kind of
what I thought going in and what the
movie actually became was great because
it really subverted all of my
expectations there are films like this
like guess who's coming to dinner with
Sidney Poitier which is one of the most
classic films about a romance with
clashing cultures but what made this
film stand out to me is its second act
because something happens that causes
Kamal to have to spend a lot of time
with Emily's parents played by Holly
Hunter and Ray Romano great to see him
in a movie let alone a good movie having
seen him in forever
and he was really funny too in this film
but that second act in which he has to
basically get close to her parents and
learn about her past and her parents
have to wrestle with their own inner
demons and so it was very different to
see in a romantic comedy not just our
two lead characters being fuzzy and
excited and then they break up and it's
sad and then there's a montage of
sadness and then they eventually get
back together and that highly original
second act really made this romantic
comedy stand out to me and I had a blast
watching it Kumail Nanjiani is a effing
revelation in this movie he is so funny
I was quite often in stitches laughing
and there's something that's captured
here that felt very real it almost felt
like I was a fly on the wall watching
real events now this is based off of a
true story and who
how much of it is fact and how much of
it is fiction and what liberties were
taken but it really did feel almost
documentary s cat times where I just
felt like I was watching real
conversations play out it doesn't feel
like anyone is overdoing it for the
camera even some of the sequences that
get more dark and a little more powerful
they still find a way to get a smile out
of it which I think if you if you take
away all the things about this movie
that are great which are amazing
performances from Zoe Kazan and Kumail
Nanjiani Ray Romano and Holly Hunter all
of the great chemistry between these
actors and the comedy take all that away
the reason this movie works so well is
because it's refreshingly unpretentious
it doesn't take itself too seriously and
it's just a blast from start to finish
it's a really funny movie and it's about
something that feels real I think a lot
of people are going to relate to Kemal
in this movie in his struggle his
parents want him to adhere to a very
strict list of guidelines they want him
to meet women and only Pakistani women
and when they want him to meet them
that's when he gets to meet them he must
be a doctor or a lawyer other things
they're not too happy about that
and if he doesn't follow these
guidelines he will be kicked out of the
family and not spoken to again and I
think a lot of people have been raised
with parents who want them to do very
specific things and want them to go in a
certain path and I think most children
as we grow into adults have a fear of
displeasing our family and that's also
captured beautifully here because it's
not just a romantic comedy that's funny
it's also about how hard it is to please
your family and how hard it is for him
to please Emily's family because it's
also as I said about getting close to
them because he's from Pakistan and
they're like you know I don't know about
you and there's there's a lot of scenes
where they have to work out their
differences and it was never handled in
that cliched way that you would expect
it to where they have like some big
moment where they explode about their
beliefs or whatever it was all very
light-hearted jokes are made about it
and this movie is just really
entertaining if I were to pinpoint some
flaws with it it goes on a little too
long towards the third act it seems like
there's a lot of sequences where they
are teasing something to happen and then
it doesn't happen you're like ah okay oh
we're going to get another chance okay
and that happens a lot now it's hard to
critique true stories sometimes because
you want to know like is this how it
actually played out and are they simply
showing us all the details and so you
don't want to say that something seems
unrealistic because maybe that actually
happened at the same time one you are
crafting a true story for film it's
important to know what details to omit
from that story to make the film work as
good as it can and the third act does
drag at times other than that the big
sik is a completely refreshing movie and
I had a great time with it I'm going to
give it an a-minus I would highly
recommend checking this one out it's
very funny and it finally opened in my
neighborhood this weekend I've been
waiting to see it guys I also want to
make sure you know to check out my
promotion with audible if you go to
audible.com slash Chris you can get a
free 30-day trial of their amazing
audiobook service they have hundreds of
thousands of audiobooks on their website
for you to download to your iPod your
tablet your computer pretty much any
device you can think of you can listen
to the audio books there they're a great
service and I just want to thank them
for continuing to sponsor my videos
their library is so vast and so
comprehensive that if you don't always
have the time to sit down and read it's
a very very useful tool for people who
want to read on the go again that's
audible.com slash Kris for a free 30-day
trial and thank you very much to audible
for continuing to sponsor my videos and
thank you to you guys for continuing to
watch you guys are the best and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]